hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the steps of phagocytosis
phagocytosis is a really important
process in the immune system carried out
by phagocytic cells or phagocytes
sometimes you hear them referred to as
phage o sites but anyway these are cells
in the immune system that actually
phagocytose which means bring in and
destroy invading bacteria as well as
just dead or dying cells within the
organism that need kind of taken care of
some examples of cells that do this are
macrophages dendritic cells and
neutrophils so these are all different
kinds of phagocytes in the immune system
phagocytosis has five basic steps first
the phagocyte has to be activated it has
to be alerted that there is either an
invading pathogen or some dead cells
that it needs to clean up then it
performs chemotaxis chemotaxis is just a
fancy word meaning that it receives a
chemical signal that tells it to move in
this direction so basically it follows a
gradient of chemicals it moves sort of
up the gradient towards the area where
that chemical is present and greater
concentration and that's how it finds
either the site of the infection or the
site of the cells that need cleaned up
once it gets there it attaches to the
cell as long as it recognizes it as
something that it is supposed to engulf
and destroy then it will ingest it and
destroy it so those are the five basic
steps we're going to look at steps three
four and five in a bit more detail now
so here I have a phagocyte
drawn just kind of a generic one all of
these projections that come out of the
cell these are what are called
pseudopodia or pseudopods pseudopod
being singular so pseudopodia which
means false eat that's where the name
comes from but they're basically these
finger-like projections that they use to
to to to engulf to bring in the thing
that they're going to destroy so let's
um draw a captured bacterium here in red
so this is a bacterium that it
recognizes basically there are little
receptors here that will recognize
certain things on the surface of
bacterial cells telling the phagocyte
that this is a bacterium we should
ingest this and eat it so it doesn't
cause an infection or to help fight an
infection that's already started so this
is what we call recognition of a PAMP by
a prr PAMP PA MP stands for pathogen
associated molecular pattern so it's
just something that is present in a
pathogen is not present in a host cell
so something like take oh ik acids or
LPS just something that's present in in
bacteria so a recognition of the PAMP of
the pattern on the bacterial cell by a
PRR PRR stands for pattern recognition
receptor it's just a receptor that
recognizes the pant so for example tlr4
is the pattern recognition receptor that
recognizes LPS which is one of those
pattern one of this pathogen associated
molecular patterns so there's some kind
of recognition and that causes the a
couple of pseudopods to come and engulf
the bacterium
it's then brought into the cell in a
membrane-bound vesicles known as a
phagosome the phagosome will then merge
with an organelle called a lysosome
and the lights of zome is full of
digestive enzymes and so when the
lysosome and the phagosome merge they
create something that's then known as a
phago lysosome and then we have the
bacterium in there that is being exposed
to all of these digestive enzymes which
will break it down so then you get the
[Music]
bacterium being broken down so that's
what's happening here and then
eventually you get something called a
residual body where really the only
thing that's left of that original
bacterium is just non-digestible
indigestion
at least is removed from the cell by the
process of exocytosis so if we summarize
here real quick we've got pseudopods
that engulf the bacterium once that PAMP
is recognized by a PR are brought in as
a phagosome merges with the lysosome the
digestive enzymes do their bed then we
eventually have exocytosis where the
remains of that bacterium are pushed out
of the cell so that right there is the
process of phagocytosis if you're
interested in watching some of my other
videos that have to do with the immune
system then check out my playlist on
immunology and thanks for watching
biology professor